so you look at my situation like
like 30 came to a
restaurant I was eating it and I what if
I would have died okay would it be oh
Freddie Gibbs oh man he was great he was
that when academics be saying I was a
great rapper on his post but nah since
you know I'm saying since tried
to jump me oh man he got jumped it's a
different thing now what if pnb rock
yeah
exactly exactly even worse and even
worse what if he would have just gave it
up
gave it up people have been like yeah
what if you would have gave it up and
lived it's a lose-lose for a so
what the y'all want from us
yeah
that's real I would have gave it up
y'all y'all would have clowned me my
career y'all oh this ass
mm-hmm
but if I fight for mine and die
oh man you shouldn't even been there man
suck my dick that man shouldn't he
shouldn't have been bothered he wasn't
bothering nobody dog you know what I'm
saying he was having a meal but
it's good at the end of the day
dog yeah having a